[Musik]
mai zusammen wir machen heute tassen
kuchen und ich habe ja so mein basic
rezept und hin und wieder habe ich auch
mal so richtig lust auf was schnelles
süßes und dann mache ich mir auch mal
ein tasten kuchen und ich habe mir
dieses mal überlegt ihr sollten wir auch
mal eure besten tassen kuchenrezepte zu
schicken da hatte ich einen aufruf über
instagram gestartet und dann haben auch
zahlreiche leute aus der community die
tassen kuchenrezepte von sich aus
geschickt und ich habe jetzt hier mal so
zwei stücke ausgesucht die mir besonders
ins auge gestochen sind und ich kann
auch die reihe gerne fortführen und noch
mehr rezepte von euch ausprobieren und
ich glaube es gab es auch noch nie auf
einem kanal dass ich eure rezepte
ausprobieren finde ich cool können wir
öfter machen
wir fangen jetzt an mit den singles
tassen kuchen von sehen ist ich hoffe
ihr spricht richtig aus liebe zu sehen
ist danke für dieses rezept ich fand's
super spannend und habe hier die zutaten
einmal bereit gelegt um sie euch mal im
überblick zu zeigen weil das ist
superschnell zusammengerückt wir
brauchen ein ei mehl backpulver flüssige
butter braunen oder rohrzucker
dann habe ich hier noch milch natürlich
zimt und vanille extrakt
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt erste flüssigen und dann
mit trockenen zutaten einfach direkt in
der tasse zusammengerührt gehe jetzt an
meine mikrowelle 600 war zirka drei bis
vier minuten ich habe aber immer so ein
auge drauf und guckt das denn nicht
verbrannt wird oder das ist einfach
nicht zu lange in der mikrowelle
verweilt und in der zwischenzeit machen
wir das cream cheese frosting das cream
cheese frosting besteht aus nur drei
zutaten frischkäse butter zucker und
milch und das verriet jetzt ganz einfach
miteinander und die finden übrigens alle
ganz genauen mengenangaben unten in der
video beschreibung
[Musik]
so ich las den cineworld tassen kuchen
jetzt noch ein wenig abkühlen und gebt
dann das prim kies frosting oben drüber
und es riecht schon richtig nach zimt in
der ganzen küche und gleich im anschluss
alle drei varianten die zweite variante
kommt von esra und zwar hat sie mir das
rezept für einen schoko tasten kuchen
gegeben
das fand ich super interessant noch
macadamia nüsse und schokolade drops ich
zeig euch jetzt hier einmal die zutaten
und zwar benötigen wir eine mutter bei
kakao da wusste ich nicht ob sie den bug
kakao oder den trecker kaum ein
dann haben wir hier mehl zucker und
milch außerdem backfest schokoladen
drops macadamia nüsse frischkäse und
vanille extrakt für dieses rezept
brauchen wir kein ganzes sondern nur ein
halbes ei und manchmal kommt es vor dass
ihr mann hat meine umrechnung tabelle
auch ein halbes ei noch zusätzlich
benötigt und so macht ihr das einfach
aufschlagen verquirlen und die hälfte
dann beiseite tun könnt ihr euch damit
den euro ergeben oder anderweitig
verwerten
[Musik]
so hier muss ich jetzt ein bisschen mehr
milch dazugeben mit sich verbindet so
nachdem ihr auch hier alles kurz
zusammengerührt habt kommt es in die
mikrowelle bei mittlerer stufe für zwei
minuten und anschließend bei höchster
stufe noch mal für zwei minuten ich bin
so gespannt riechen tut er schon sehr
gut der show protest und kuchen gekühlt
gerade kurz achte sieht schon mal sehr
gut aus und jetzt zeige ich euch jetzt
drittes mein classic basic tassen kuchen
rezept das ist ein mann in die tassen
kuchen mit schokostückchen mein rezept
ist tatsächlich freie sofa ich
persönlich am besten aber ich kann mich
doch eines besseren belehren lassen wir
probleme gleich und zwar benötigen wir
milch mehl backpulver zucker neutrales
öl ich nehme gerne sonnenblumenöl
außerdem back feste schokoladen drops
oder tanks und vanille extrakt und da
versuche ich jetzt auch alles in meiner
tasse
[Musik]
mein tasten kuchen kommt jetzt bei 900
war zirka zwei bis zweieinhalb minuten
in die mikrowelle aber hab da auch gerne
immer wieder ein auge drauf weil jede
mikrowelle ist auch noch mal ein
bisschen anders
so auch meine taschen kuchen kommt jetzt
noch ein leckeres mascarpone frosting
das ist super super schnell
zusammengerührt denn zum schnellen 1000
koren letzte fast der auch ein schnelles
frosting und dafür habe ich hier
mascarpone etwas rohrzucker ein bisschen
vanille extrakt und das rühren wir nur
ganz kurz zusammen wenn es das frosting
auch schon fertig und wird später
richtig schön fest und ob das ist so ein
kleiner fotoblogger move sag ich mal
gebe ich noch getrocknet werden die sind
so hübsch aus probiert es mal aussieht
nicht nur möglich außerdem schmeckt dann
natürlich auch noch mal so ein bisschen
fruchtig
[Musik]
so das war's auch schon und das gebe ich
mir gleich in einen spritzbeutel und
dann kommt das auf meine abgekühlten
tassen kuchen
[Musik]
so ich würde mal sagen gar nicht lange
drumherum quatschen ich bin sehr
gespannt wie das ganze jetzt schmeckt
also mein 1000 kuchen kenne ich
natürlich geschmack nicht aber die
anderen zwei eben nicht sondern an der
stelle nochmal vielen vielen dank für
alle e mails wie gesagt es kann gerne
das format erweitern um noch weitere
rezepte von euch ausprobieren aber dafür
müsst ihr feedback in den kommentaren
müssen damit ich auch weiß ob über
interessiert daran sein
so jetzt probieren wir im cinema walls
tassen kuchen ich bin gespannt das ist
natürlich alles auch schon abgekühlt
hier noch mega heiß in die aus der
mikrowelle rauskommen daher vorsicht
leute ist ein brauner teil mit cream
cheese frosting m leute diese dieser
tassen kuchen schmeckt richtig gut dass
mich also ich war total skeptisch bin
ich ganz ehrlich auch wenn ihr es
natürlich nicht an gesehen habt aber der
name hat mich halt mega angezogen szene
mit rolls tassen kuchen ich liebe ja
zimt röhrchen sinken die mich über alles
und wer zimt mag wird diesen tassen
kuchen liebt wie genua zum schoko tassen
kuchen mit macadamia nüssen und schoko
drops da war ja nur ein halbes ei drin
da war kein öl drin
sehr interessant also der teig ist
relativ hart würde ich sagen aber jetzt
nicht so stein habe also er ist er fest
sein muss man so was nicht negativ
gemeint jetzt probiere ich mal
hmm also der schmeckt lecker schokolade
und guter sicht bacau genau ich glaube
so meintest du das auch liebe es weil
dort ist ja noch zucker drin und der tri
cacau ist ja schon sehr süß doch sehr
lecker bis hin zu fest ich mag es auch
wenn kassen kuchen sofa die sind so ein
bisschen wie brownies aber dennoch sehr
sehr gut sehr lecker kann ich auch
empfehlen also gut dass ich mir genau
diese zwei rezepte ausgesucht habe wobei
super viele spannende rezepte gab aber
nichtsdestotrotz habe ich auch mein
eigenes rezept auch noch mit
reingenommen das ist mein basic rezept
und da probiere ich jetzt auch wenn ich
weiß jetzt schmeckt weil wollte endlich
schmecken würde dann würde ich glaube
ich gar nicht erst hier mit verfilmen
hätte das rezept ja schon verändert aber
können jetzt noch ein
also der schmeckt tatsächlich wie
vanille kuchen und schoko drops also
wirklich wie kuchen
das vermisse ich hier auch überhaupt
nicht also in der konsistenz habe ich
nichts auszusetzen also könnt ihr 1000
brauchen auch theoretisch gesehen
frey super hinbekommen so was sagt ihr
leute was ist euer favorit was möchtet
immer ausprobieren hinterlassen wir
gerne euer feedback und ansonsten freue
ich mich über einen deutlichen nach oben
für dieses coole video mal was ganz
anderes und sage bis zum nächsten mal
auf die sketche